IT IS TIME FOR OUR NEXT THE
GAME SIX-SIX-SIX FLAGS!
AMUSEMENTS A PARKS ARE A GREAT
PLACE TO FIND OUT WHAT YOU ARE
ACTUALLY MADE OF, AND IT USUALLY
TURNS OUT IT IS EITHER POOP,
PEE, OR A PUKE AND A OR A
MIXTURE THAT I CALL POOPY PUKE.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE TURDUCKEN, BUT
GROSS.
COMEDIANS I AM GOING TO SHOW YOU
A THUMBNAIL FROM A VIDEO CLIP OF
SOME PEOPLE ENJOYING AMUSEMENT
PARK RIDES AND FOR 250-POINT YOU
GOTTA TELL ME WHAT HAPPENS.
FIRST ONE --
GUY TAKES A SELFIE AND DROPS
HIS PHONE INTO HIS OWN FACE OR
GUYS CAN'T SEEM TO STOP PASSING
OUT.
WHICH ONE? PAUL.
>> I'M GONNA SAY THE PASSING OUT
ONE.
>> Chris: OKAY, LET'S FIND OUT.
>> THAT WAS AMAZING.
>> SO FULFILLING.
>> PASSING OUT TO HIM LOOKS A
LOT LIKE (BLEEP).
LIKE, THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE.
>> THAT RIDE IS CALLED THE
VINEGAR STROKE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: WELL DONE. WELL DONE.
>> BUT TO BE TRUTHFUL WHEN YOU
GET ON THAT RIDE IT SAYS YOU
MUST BE THIS HARD TO GET ON THIS
RIDE.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE.
GIRL SCREAMS SUSHI GRADE
OBSCENITIES OR DAD PUKES ALL
OVER HIS DAUGHTER.
>> I WANT THEM BOTH.
>> Chris: NICK KROLL.
>> I, JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
WHAT IS SUSHI GRADE OBSCENITIES.
>> Chris: I MEAN like REALLY
CHOICE, AMAZING ..
>> OH, OKAY.
>> Chris: LIKE FOR A CHILD TO
SPIT OUT SOME REALLY SWEET
SWEARS.
>> NOT STUFF ABOUT LIKE, SALMON
[BLEEP].
I AM SAYING DAD PUKES ALL OVER
HIS DAUGHTER.
>> PLEASE. PLEASE.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> Chris: WHOA!
AND THEN THEY GET TO THE BOTTOM
AND HE'S IS LIKE LET'S GO AGAIN.